hey crazies i'm here to burst your
bubble again
this picture of the atom is wrong the
real atom
is far weirder than we ever could have
imagined so weird that we had to rule
out
everything else before we could accept
it and judging from the length of the
video you can see we're going to take
our time with this
all right we can't really understand
where we are until we see where we've
been
to the timeline debates about atoms have
been going on since ancient greece
democritus first suggested that matter
was made of tiny
invisible bits he called them etomos
because he thought they were indivisible
this is why we call them atoms today of
course aristotle thought it was a stupid
idea
i still do why did i make you anyway
the debate raged on for over 2 000
years finally the 20th century was fast
approaching and we made some headway
thompson discovered the electron in 1897
and proposed a simple model of the atom
in 1904
negative electrons floating in a
positive mist
rutherford proposed a better one in 1911
with an atomic nucleus but he wouldn't
discover the proton until 1919.
unfortunately that nucleus couldn't be
made of just protons
that wouldn't predict the masses on the
periodic table we had to wait until 1932
for the discovery of the neutron to
explain it
neutral particles are really hard to
find all right what do we know
so far negative electrons are on the
outside
surrounding a positive nucleus that
nucleus is made of protons and neutrons
but by the time we knew about neutrons
we already knew electrons didn't orbit
like this
this picture is wrong so what does it
really look like
well it looks like this
but that's probably not what you were
hoping for isn't there like a visual
model or something
like this but more accurate okay i'll
give it a shot but prepare to have your
mind blown
things got really weird in the 1920s so
let's try to keep this as concrete as
possible
you are all seeing me because light is
emitted by your screens
we saw in a previous video that
individual atoms can emit light too
it's called an emission spectrum and it
can tell us what kind of atom it is
any model we come up with for the atom
must explain that
let's start with the most obvious
question how do atoms emit light
energy levels say we have hydrogen gas
in a closed
glass tube if we run a bunch of
electricity through it the electrons
will absorb some of the electrical
energy
when those same electrons fall back down
the energy gets emitted as light
there's a slight problem though if that
electron could jump to any energy
it could emit any color of light but we
know it only emits
these four colors one red one blue green
and two violets the only conclusion that
electron can't have any energy at once
it can only have specific energies
called energy levels
and jumps between those levels emit or
absorb specific colors of light
we number these levels 1 2 3
4 5 etc all the way to infinity the
electron isn't allowed to be anywhere in
between them
not even for a moment while it jumps it
must disappear from one
and reappear on the other i know crazy
right
anyway back to hydrogen the four jumps
for hydrogen's visible spectrum are
three to two
four to two five to two and sixty two
any other jump
emits light that isn't visible but why
though
that's the question that takes us
straight into madness when a measurement
can only have certain values
we say it's quantized and the light
emitted or absorbed during a jump
between those levels
is called a quantum that's right we're
talking about quantum mechanics
we know that when things orbit by
gravity they can have
any energy they'd like classical
mechanics is the mechanism for how that
works
electrons don't seem to obey those rules
though so what we needed was a quantum
mechanics
a mechanism for quantum particles back
to the timeline
in 1924 a french physicist named louis
de bruy
proposed an idea what if electrons had
wave properties
the electron can only exist in certain
energy levels
because there must be a whole number of
wavelengths present
they're not actually orbits at all this
was some serious out of the box thinking
but it solved a couple problems
one why could electrons only be in
certain energy levels
cutting a wavelength up would be like
cutting an electron up
ridiculous a jump from one level to
another is just a gain or loss of whole
electron wavelengths
two accelerating charges must emit light
why don't electron orbits just collapse
in orbit is accelerated motion electrons
should continuously lose energy to light
and fall into the nucleus but they don't
why not
they're not actually orbiting they're
just waves but if a wave like
light can come in little packets like a
particle and little packets like
electrons can look like waves
why stop at electrons in 1926 an
austrian physicist named irvin
schrodinger
ran with that thought if all particles
are also waves
then we're going to need a wave equation
to predict their behavior
maxwell's equations gave us something
like this for light so that's the kind
of thing we want for all particles
using the total energy of a particle
what we call the hamiltonian
we get something that looks like this
which is designed to help us figure out
this
the wave function an equation to contain
all the wave properties of a particle
another slight problem though even if we
think of the electron itself as
waving in space a wave is still
accelerated motion
it should still be continuously emitting
light and collapsing into the nucleus
the only solution is that the electron
isn't waving wait wait didn't you just
say that it was waving
well yes and no okay i think it's time
for another summary
the nucleus is made of protons and
neutrons and there is a cloud of
electrons surrounding it
the behavior of all those particles is
governed by wave functions
but if the particles themselves aren't
doing the waving what is waving
later in 1926 a german physicist named
max born butted into the conversation
and suggested maybe just maybe it's a
wave of probability
i know i know it's nuts but it fixes all
the problems
i think richard feynman put it best when
he said the wave function for an
electron in an atom does not describe
a smeared out electron with a smooth
charge density the electron is either
here
or there or somewhere else but wherever
it is
it is a point charge huh all right this
is how it works
even though a particle itself isn't a
wave its properties are
where it is what it's doing how much
energy it has
all these things are wave shaped but
they're only waves of probability
say the position of an electron looks
like this it's not smeared out across
all space
it just doesn't have a definite position
it's most likely to be here
but also pretty likely to be here or
here
and it's probably not going to be any of
these places but it could be almost
anywhere so what happens if i try to
measure where it is smartypants then
it'll only be one place
you just can't predict where that'll be
the act of measuring it
changes what the wave looks like it
changes the wave from this
to maybe this but even then it's not
exactly definite
there's still a little wiggle room
that's what the uncertainty principle is
all about but the measurement doesn't
destroy the wave
it just collapses it to a simpler shape
luckily
some measurements can be made together
the energy the magnitude of angular
momentum
and at least part of its orientation can
all be measured together
so those are allowed to be definite all
at the same time
again though there's a little spread a
little wiggle room
which is what gives emission lines their
thickness but the definiteness of these
measurements gives us a lot of
information about electrons and atoms
information we use to categorize them
into shells and orbitals
okay final summary the nucleus is made
of protons and neutrons and there is a
cloud of electrons surrounding it
the behavior of all those particles is
governed by wave functions
but those are waves of probability so
everything's at least a little bit vague
we're not sure exactly what anything is
doing or exactly where it is
but we can make some great educated
guesses and that's enough
to predict the entire periodic table
so got any questions please ask in the
comments thanks for liking and sharing
this video don't forget to subscribe if
you want to keep up with us
and until next time remember it's okay
to be a little crazy
we tried out a new type of video last
time and everyone seemed to love it
but jeremiah pendley asked if it would
take away from my other content that's a
solid no jeremiah i just don't want to
do the same thing every time i need
variety so i'm mixing it into the lineup
you